previously on TV since one paw is sold
into slavery or one foot dies or No Deal
oh I see how it is soos you get a
producer credit and all of a sudden the
good doctor wants to go by Ted Geisel
again a few seconds later he's back
Susan it up pick a name Ted age a
credits didn't we just see this exact
same title just 40 seconds ago do you
think we forgot what we were watching
that quickly oh sure the who's loved
Christmas and all but who will speak for
the trees trim the tree bingo balls who
fou fluff are we sure dr. Seuss didn't
have his doctorate in manscaping fat
wreath was a traditional wreath with the
hole in the middle where did the demonic
star topper jack-in-the-box come from
was it hell cuz I think it was hell do
what the Whoville liked Christmas a lot
Carl operation The Grinch hated
Christmas huh
Dean so gosh why no one quite knows the
reason except Ron Howard you seem pretty
sure it was because he was bullied in
school so ken and Sherman and I guess
the most likely reason of all may have
been that he's hot
there's two sizes too small I heard this
is the same issue with [ __ ] YouTube
television movie and music centers where
did all these kids come from is this the
Whoville orphanage I mean sure could be
a giant who family except they all look
exactly the same age do who viens have
kids in litters also where are the
adults there are kids in here shooting
arrows riding trains playing trumpets
atop giant stilts and riding
rollerskates while holding ordinate
badminton rackets whose whose are these
no how would the Grinch be able to hear
a thing coming from Whoville I get that
sound travels up but with the amount of
wind and the fact that he lives in a
[ __ ] gave 10,000 feet up this would seem
to be a non-issue and later he'll
mention them beating their Trump took
hers and slamming their sluice lunker's
honestly sometimes I think Suzy and
rhyme is just a play-by-play of old
timey porn can we talk for just a second
about the airflow physics and the
switches necessary for a brass
instrument with this many bells every
bell would need a separate switch to
redirect the sound
that you could only play one at a time
anyway it's almost like dr. Seuss didn't
even care about real-world physics and
consequences and this electro whoo
cardio SHhhh Lux has the exact opposite
issue what a for whose need to blow into
it when it only has one Bell also how
are any of them even supposed to see the
one who is conducting I mean the one who
who is conducting I mean the one who
whom is conducting whatever one of them
is facing completely backwards as long
[Music]
so you're gonna feast I wasn't sure I
got that these Russian nesting chefs are
delivering this treat by focusing on
presentation and style more than
practicality and affordability so it
makes complete sense that it appears to
be some kind of Apple product the song
is so perfect even this movie Grinch has
to remove a few cents but what is he
even sowing here he can't make it any
more of a sleeve than it already is
I think it would have been less weird if
there just been a reindeer farm nearby
as opposed to him having antlers mounted
on his wall for no reason if I can't you
know whose movie I want to see max how
the hell did he wind up with this Green
Goblin he could have been raised by him
or he would have just added up some sort
of Christmas Cujo did Grinch ego dog
shopping and yes I'm aware there's a
follow-up book dedicated to answering
this question but I'm too lazy to even
read rhyming picture books so I'm just
going to assume so
[Music]
this works this they started down for
the hoes by the who's Laius news or
whose nocturnal because as bright as
this snow is it's definitely day right
now I get that it's a cartoon and that
he's a real son of a Grinch but if
you're asking me how much animal cruelty
played for laughs in a kid flick I can
take before I get uncomfortable I'm just
saying two full minutes might be close
when he came out square considering this
is a soos world and right ankles don't
exist I'm pretty sure that no one even
knows what a square is it's probably
called the town fly first noodler since
max is on the ground who the hell is he
making eyes at here I can overlook a lot
of silliness and cartoons like this
anti-gravity ornament somehow climbing a
tree to take out the other ornaments but
these ornaments rolling into a hole in
the floorboard and then reappearing
falling through the rain gutters has
bothered my mind beyond what I can
handle
I think Grinch is doing a service for
these kids here think of the sticky
hands and now they will be covered in
ants by morning if he doesn't take these
candy canes from them also how did we
not all grow up with constant nightmares
on Christmas Eve look at that face that
Green Monster was going to eat those
children I swear it it's becoming more
and more clear the animators of this
special also took all the who hash they
could find also why does all the food
have whoo in front of it on the labels
it's not like we go to the store and
pick up human jello I think the real
question is how to freeze speaking so
fluently if you're barely two are they
putting in who hash and the ones speck
of food that he left in the house was a
crumb that was even too small for a bug
so did he leave it or not and if it was
too small for the mouse why did the
mouse seem interested in it before it
was snatched away Christmas special
can't even stay true to its own direct
narration this is really the quickest
way to do this of the Grinch as many
evils I'm thinking lack of efficiency
might be top of the list
with no to the top yeah we used to do
that in college we called it the
double-decker okay fine
contentment in all situations loves more
important than material possessions blah
blah but this entire town just got
violated in horrendous way and every
single one of these Stepford Hoos wakes
up smiling and singing can we at least
let them work through it a bit also if
we needed any more proof that the Hoos
are just a big cult may I point you to
the giant glowing deity in the middle of
their circle maybe Christmas he thought
doesn't come from a store yeah but this
blu-ray did and the countless other
movies clothing and other merchandising
this book has resulted in I'm just
saying there's a balance in the world as
all the true meaning of Christmas came
through and the Grinch found the
strength of ten ridges plus two so
that's what we've been doing wrong my
trainer has me doing silly things like
squats and presses when I should be
reading the Nativity story while
listening to the Christmas shoes to get
my swole on he brought everything back
all the food for the feast but they
still locked him up for two decades at
least and as for the dog even with full
repentance an accessory to the crime he
got his own max sentence for in Whoville
you see green brown tall or small no
creature exists above the rule of law
also does Cindy thinks Santa is having
lunch with them or has her belief system
been completely broken and she will be
an untrusting basket case for the rest
of her life I leaned toward the ladder
I'm totally getting a sin back for this
being only 26 minutes and not starring
Jim Carrey or being a pointless over
long 20 18 holiday cash grab
you're amazing dude
thanks I like to play
[Music]
did you chop down this tree today it's
ripe nice firm because a prominent
Indian guru and his followers brought it
our vision was to create a community
based on compassion and sharing
[Music]
[Applause]
Christmas Day will always be just as
long as we have we
[Music]